he's out questioning shirtless trust
resign the Prime Minister sack in her
Chancellor after just 38 days in the job
leaving behind a party
a government and a prime minister in
total turmoil
looking uncomfortable before she even
began Liz trust knows she's in trouble
good afternoon
my conviction that this country needs to
go for growth is rooted in my personal
experience
I know what it's like to grow up
somewhere that isn't feeling the
benefits of growth
I saw what that meant
and I'm not prepared to accept that for
our country
I want a country where people can get
good jobs new businesses can set up and
families can afford an even better life
that's why from day one I've been
ambitious for growth
since the 2008 financial crisis the
potential of this great country has been
held back by persistently weak growth
I want to deliver a low tax high-wage
high growth economy
it's what I was elected by my party to
do
that mission remains
people across this country rightly want
stability
that's why we acted to support
businesses and households with their
energy costs this winter
it's also the case that global economic
conditions are worsening due to the
continuation of Putin's appalling war in
Ukraine and on top of this debt was
amassed helping people through the
covered pandemic blaming Putin and the
pandemic while sticking to the same
economic argument in principle but in
practice everything's falling apart
but it is clear that parts of our mini
budget went further and faster the
markets were expecting
so the way we are delivering our mission
right now has to change
we need to act now to reassure the
markets of our fiscal discipline
I have therefore decided to keep the
increase in corporation tax that was
planned by the previous government
this will raise 18 billion pounds per
year
it will act as a down payment on our
full medium-term fiscal plan which will
be accompanied by a forecast from the
Independent obr
we will do whatever is necessary to
ensure debt is falling as a share of the
economy in the medium term
we will control the size of the state to
ensure that taxpayers money is always
well spent
our public sector will become more
efficient to deliver world-class
services for the British people
and spending will grow less rapidly than
previously planned the second policy
U-turn in less than two weeks hoping to
calm the markets but a PM signal in
panic this government in free fall I met
the former Chancellor earlier today
I was incredibly sorry to lose him
he is a great friend
and he shares my vision to set this
country on the path to Grace
today
I have asked Jeremy Hunt to become the
new Chancellor
he's one of the most experienced and
widely respected government ministers
and parliamentarians
and he shares my convictions and
Ambitions for our country
he will deliver the medium-term fiscal
plan at the end of this month
he will see through the support we are
providing to help families and
businesses including our energy price
guarantee that's protecting people from
higher energy bills this winter
and he will drive our mission to go for
growth including taking forward the
supply side reforms that our country
needs
dark days for a PM who turned up in
black to a news conference in which she
said very little but which Illustrated
just how bad this really is
we owe it to the next Generation to
improve our economic performance
to deliver higher wages new jobs and
better public services and to ease the
burden of debt
I have acted decisively today because my
priority is ensuring our country's
economic stability
as prime minister I will always act in
the National interest
this is always my first consideration
I want to be honest this is difficult
but we will get through this storm and
we will deliver the strong and sustained
growth that can transform the prosperity
of our country for generations to come a
critical juncture for her government
marked by speech lasting barely four
minutes and then a q a session which
made her perilous position look even
worse thank you prime minister clearly a
difficult day can you explain to the
public why you think you should remain
as prime minister given you've junk to
keep tax cuts that led you to be elected
and got rid of your Chancellor
I'm absolutely determined to see through
what I've promised to deliver a higher
growth more prosperous United Kingdom to
see us through the storm we Face we've
already delivered the energy price
guarantee making sure people aren't
facing huge bills this winter
but it was right in the face of the
issues that we had
that I acted decisively to ensure that
we have economic stability because that
is vitally important to people and
businesses right across our country
a country which has already seen one
policy U-turn today another and the man
charged with implementing her policies
gone you were the one that wanted to Cut
45p Rate you stood on a platform to win
the leadership of the conservative party
on a platform to cut corporation tax you
and the chancellor the ex-chancellor
designed this budget together in
lockstep we're told at times in Secrets
the two of you he has to go because of
the Fallout from it how come you get to
stay
well my priority is making sure we
deliver the economic stability that our
country needs that's why I had to take
the difficult decisions I've taken today
the mission Remains the Same we do need
to raise our country's economic growth
levels we do need to deliver for people
across the country we're committed to
delivering on the energy price guarantee
which people are already seeing in their
bills but ultimately we also need to
make sure that we have economic
stability and I have to act in the
National interest as prime minister a
prime minister not in control and out of
her depth excuse the bluntness Prime
Minister but given everything that has
happened what credibility do you have to
continue governing
what I've done today
is made sure that we have economic
stability in this country
Jeremy Hunters Chancellor is somebody
who shares my desire for a high growth
low-tax economy but we recognize because
of current market issues we have to
deliver the mission in a different way
and that's what we are absolutely
committed to do achieving that stability
and what is a very difficult time
globally
the former Tory Chancellor Philip
Hammond has just said that you have
totally trashed the Tory parties
election winning reputation for economic
competence will you apologize to your
party another question prompting another
awkward pause none of this easy well I
am determined to deliver
on what I set out when I campaigned to
be party leader we need to have a high
growth economy but we have to recognize
that we are facing very difficult issues
as a country and it was right in the
National interest that I made the
decisions I've made today to restore
that economic stability so we can
deliver first of all helping people
through this winter and next winter with
our energy bills but also making sure
that our country is on the long-term
footing for sustainable economic growth
thank you very much everybody
a question to sum up the mood in this
room
chaos inside Downing Street clear on the
outside too descent in every corner of
Westminster and a party deeply divided
do you feel like you've been betrayed by
the Prime Minister this man was until
today perhaps the prime minister's
biggest Ally in his departure letter
quasiquartung made clear this was not
his choice writing you've asked me to
stand aside as your Chancellor I have
accepted allies parted we have been
colleagues and friends for many years
but promising loyalty and support from
the back benches to Liz trust responded
to say she was deeply sorry to lose her
Chancellor despite sacking him and
thanking him for putting the national
interest fast but this also about a
prime minister trying to save herself
and she'll need the support of her party
to do it all of us on the conservative
back benches owe it to the government to
try and give our best support while
offering thoughts and views on aspects
of the plan that we may feel have
strayed from the 2019 Manifesto or need
delivering in a different way much of
that will now fall on Jeremy Hunt at a
cabinet constant do you have any place
that you'll be able to restore the
financial markets there with a
significant challenge ahead we're now on
the fourth conservative Chancellor this
year in fact we're on the fourth
conservative Chancellor since July this
year the truth is another change in who
is running the treasury another Tory
Chancellor isn't the answer to the
challenges that we face as a country the
Tories are out of ideas they're out of
time
ousting her Chancellor in a bid to save
herself Liz Trust might have bought
herself a little bit of time today but
nothing has changed and in fact she
could have made things worse the sacking
of quasi-quartung revealing to her party
the full-blown panic number 10 is now in
Tory ministers and Grandes tell me it's
now a question of when not if she has to
go one former cabinet minister told me
we know how this ends another said she
has to go even a serving cabinet
minister admitted to me this isn't going
to last
just six weeks in and now the only talk
is about when she'll be gone a party out
of control a PM all but out of power and
a country in crisis Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster